the daytime emmys now Kelly Clarkson may
be headed for a divorce but she is full
of thanks for her soon-to-be ex Shelley
Clarkson look mama paid off
I mean we're winners right now that's
awesome so you know talking got me to
winning I cannot believe it it's our
first season so thank you so much to the
Academy
Kelly's win comes three weeks after
filing for divorce from husband and
executive producer Brandon Blackstock 36
minutes after picking up any gold Kelly
tweeted Brandon saying thank you so much
for believing in me and convincing me to
do the Kelly Clarkson show think there
might be a reconciliation that's
unlikely Kelly's wedding ring is still
gone and the Emmy goes to
Alex Trebek Jeopardy's Alex Trebek -
home the gold for outstanding game show
host speaking as one who has now been
nominated 32 times and has won seven
times I think I can say with some degree
of authority that winning is nicer I
never expected to win a Daytime Emmy
from my house
Kevin presented Ellen DeGeneres to first
17th Daytime Emmy but did just hint she
might be ready to retire from hosting
when her contracts up in 2022 I intend
to use the next two years of my show as
a platform for change to amplify voices
of black people and people of color and
to educate my audience CB s led with 19
wins in all including Best Drama Series
for the young and the restless' and big
congrats go to our friend and special
correspondent Heather Tom winning
Outstanding Lead Actress in a Drama
Series number six how about the Hat
Kelsey Grammer called my name and I was
just like what and I'm yelling for James
I like James James anybody like say
who's downstairs watching like paw
patrol or whatever yeah and I'm James
Holmes I'm like right I know everybody
had to put speeches in ahead of time
like that's kind of I think that's kind
of weird
I won't lie it was odd to have to like
record a speech before him I did it but
it felt a little a little awkward but
you know whatever everyone had to do it
and actually it was kind of amazingly
fun you know it rain I was in my bedroom
and the Emmy goes to and the Emmy goes
to the Emmy goes to
this year's award ceremony looked a lot
different no red carpet and socially
distant presentations so how exactly did
they pull off handing out 19 awards even
the presenters weren't allowed to know
who the winners were so when they were
recording their presentation of each
category they had to open five envelopes
one for every possible outcome for only
the editor to know which one made it
into the show
neither the hosts the presenters nor the
nominees themselves knew who won until
they watched with the fans on Friday
night well we were definitely watching
going for Emmy win number five and the
Emmy goes to
[Music]
Entertainment Tonight man we are all so
grateful
[Music]